hi I'm Tim Baker Tim Baker that's
Timothy this is Tim we did not force him
to dress like that and I think there's
been a terrible mistake I was told that
you media rockstars sat at the covering
Call of Duty so here I am with my gaming
expertise covering beautycon dead beauty
cons of convention they hold every year
all about fashion makeup Fitness SC
makeup I'm sorry what what a fashion
fashion do you do do you do you work out
and stuff like that like that much how
much do you weigh let me take that bag
that was horrible question what's your
routine what do I have to do to get to
your awesome status thanks to
billion-dollar brows for making my brows
billion dollars I have gotten Matt Damon
a few times who have you done make a for
The Real Housewives of Atlanta we've
gone with my fabulous
anymore
hip-hop so like other urban figures just
like me weird al' count okay I was like
Matt Damon to me Matt Damon what does a
guy like me have to do my name is short
for Timothy one last thing I really like
your skirt what are you doing here
I have no idea so I'm here with Julie
and she says she can make me prettier
the lashes are coming it's wet my eyes
feel wet I've never done this ever
before
alright so I was told that I have to get
a manicure or else I'll never be loved
yeah Megaman Megaman blue yes so if I
had sparkly nails on the street you
totally want to hold my hand
perfect
that's it for me at beautycon 2014 we
learned a lot today about makeup fashion
and fitness diesei makeup we met earlier
today get it together
yeah I went around and got myself
cleaned up okay
really different oh is that like a like
a good different or bad different about
your girl if you're all timid and shy we
got to ask earlier but what do you look
for in a guy I just I go crazy for that
nerdy gamer type of guys laugh oh do you
like Legend of Zelda Link to the Past
thanks for new media rockstars guys make
sure to subscribe and like to them
Twitter and all that I gotta go back
into the game fool